beide schulen in kitas hört man überall
nur noch die worte quarantäne pcr test
und wir warten auf antworten von der
regierung die noch im amt ist oder von
der regierung die gerade ins amt will
was ist jetzt was wird aus weihnachten
wo ist das problem uns mal winterfest zu
machen da werden schon wieder
weihnachtsmärkte abgeblasen wo die buden
doch gerade aufgebaut wurden jetzt
spricht man schon wieder von hochrisiko
gebiet von lockdown usw was wird in den
nächsten wochen hier in deutschland
corona mäßig passieren darüber sprechen
wir mit unseren kollegen corona
politikexperte julius bär mittlerweile
herzlich willkommen erstmal bei uns im
studio wie stark ist die politik selbst
aktuell verunsichert wie sehr ist sie
selbst wieder ins schwimmen geraten nein
man muss ja mal festhalten wir hatten
alle gedacht die impfung wird uns aus
dieser krise heraus tragen der die
wichtigste sache ist die impfung und wir
impfen uns in die freiheit hinein haben
viele politiker immer wieder bemüht
dieses bild und jetzt haben wir gemerkt
mit der delta variante und weiteren
begleitumständen nicht der impfquote die
wir uns erhofft oder erwünscht haben
reicht ist möglicherweise nicht es gibt
fünf durchbrüche die nicht die große
zahl ausmachen aber trotzdem relevant
sind in den kalten häusern es gibt diese
große zahl 15 bis 17 millionen menschen
die sie gar nicht impfen lassen möchten
und trotz dieser großen teil trotz
dieser zwei drittel die geimpft sind
kommen wir wieder hin diese
problemsituation und damit haben glaube
ich sehr sehr wenige menschen gerechnet
problemsituation sagst du jetzt hat der
chef des robert koch-instituts heute
sich wieder neben den
gesundheitsminister gesetz hier in
berlin und die beiden haben informiert
über die korona lage in deutschland das
war wieder eine absolute alarm
pressekonferenz schauen wir mal rein was
lothar wieler also der chef des robert
koch-instituts davor ja einer knappen
stunde gesagt hat einige bundesländer
haben bereits die höchste stufe dieses
planes die stufe 2 erreicht in dieser
stufe zwei reicht zweig alleine nicht
mehr aus um das infektionsgeschehen
einzudämmen für stufe 2 1 für das robert
koch institut deshalb weiter kontakt
reduktion dass man zb bei
großveranstaltungen
veranstaltungen die personenzahl
reduziert oder ein verbot erwägt das man
aber in erwägung ziehen sollte auch bars
oder clubs zu
fünf nach zwölf ist es sagte lothar
wieder auch in dieser pressekonferenz
also zu spät julius bögen müssen muss
man sagen zu spät um da die situation
irgendwie über den winter hinweg noch zu
retten man muss sich das mal vorstellen
während in deutschland fast nirgendwo
außer in sachsen zweig flächendeckend
gilt spricht lothar wieler schon davon
dass zweig schon längst nicht mehr
ausreicht dass man selber nachdenken
muss bei veranstaltungen härtere
maßnahmen einzuführen eventuell
veranstaltungen abzusagen bars und clubs
zu schließen das klingt schon wieder ein
wenig nach dem bösen l wird nach dem
wort locker und hat doch gesagt es gibt
regionen denen ist die dynamik so stark
dass man ohne zusätzliche maßnahmen das
nicht mehr aufhalten kann das heißt
lothar wieler warnt nicht nur er sagt
auch was er will nämlich mindestens mal
wieder einen lockt online also genau wie
du sagst die politik die uns vorbereitet
schon wieder auf den nächsten lockdown
auf die nächsten schärferen maßnahmen
die das wort alleine noch nicht in den
mund nehmen will der gesundheitsminister
hat genauso heute auch alle an stimmung
verbreitet hier in berlin von einer
knappen stunde
was so hohe infektionszahlen bei
gleichzeitig noch zu geringen impfquote
bedeuten sehen wir bereits jetzt auf den
intensivstationen in einigen regionen in
deutschland insbesondere in sachsen
thüringen und bayern es gibt dort
kliniken die sind heute schon über dem
limit in diesen regionen
besteht aktuell das risiko wenn sie ein
notfall sind schlaganfall herzinfarkt
dass dort nicht immer sofort vor ort die
kapazitäten zur verfügung stehen die sie
sonst gewohnt werden
herr damit also auch angesprochen die
situation in den krankenhäusern die
situation auf den intensivstationen
für das boden das heißt du dir auch
einmal angeschaut für eine reportage
hier für uns für bild welchen eindruck
hast du gewonnen hast du das gefühl dass
dort genug pflegekräfte da sind dass sie
genug bezahlt werden dass es eine
situation gibt die auch mit ausblick in
die zukunft das ganze für uns alle
irgendwie händelbar macht also ich
glaube diese bewertung ist auf den
einzelfall runtergebrochen sehr
schwierig wenn ich mich als person
überfordert fühle wenn ich einen
patienten behandelt gerade und ein
anderer patient irgendwie hilferufe und
ich kann ihm nicht helfen weil das
personal so eng geschnürt dann bin ich
überfordert oder bin ich in einer
stresssituation auf das gesamtsystem
betrachtet muss man ja als politiker ein
bisschen sachlich an so eine sache
rangehen haben wir glaube ich eines der
der stärksten systeme der welt ja meine
unfassbar hohe anzahl an den sieg betten
pro kopf und wir haben dauerhaften
deutschland fast 20.000 menschen die
dort behandelt werden nach unfällen nach
herzinfarkten krebsoperation wie auch
immer und im augenblick sind eben 2800
corona patienten mit dabei es werden
nicht mehr patienten behandelt aber der
aufwand für diese patienten ist eben
etwas höher weil hygienemaßnahmen
eingehalten werden müssen um eben nicht
die anderen patienten die dort liegen
die da immer liegen zusätzlich zu
gefährden das haben wir schon gesagt die
politik ist unentschlossen aktuell was
tun in den nächsten wochen vor
weihnachten wie tatsächlich deutschland
winterfest machen wie der wohl künftige
kanzler olaf scholz dass er gestern
formuliert hat andere länder sind da
weiter schauen wir einmal auf die
niederlande die haben jetzt wieder
beschlossen ein lockdown light
einzuführen österreich unsere nachbarn
im süden also haben den lockdown für
ungeimpfte eingeführt und wir erinnern
uns in der ganzen corona krise war es
immer so in deutschland hat man gesagt
nee nee nee das kommt hier nicht
österreich hat es gemacht und bis
spätestens zwei wochen später hatten wir
denselben mist ihren deutschland auch
wird es genauso wieder laufen also
österreich läuft vorneweg und
deutschland hat hinterher kriegen wir
auch den lockdown für ungeimpfte also
niemand nimmt dieses wort in den mund
aber wenn ich darüber nachdenken dass
wir flächendeckend die 2g regel
einführen oder möglich machen in sachsen
passiert das ganze jetzt schon ist es ja
am ende des tages nichts anderes
ungeimpfte dürfen dann zu arbeiten gehen
und meinetwegen noch spazieren aber sie
dürfen eben nicht mehr im restaurant ins
kino und so weiter und wer vom
alltäglichen leben ausgeschlossen wird
wieder wie das wort schon sagt lock down
ja der ist in meinen augen eben genau
diese situation und da sollten wir dann
am ende des tages auch ehrlich machen
und sagen liebe ungeimpfte wenn ihr euch
eben nicht überzeugen lassen wollt mit
guten argumenten dann gilt das jetzt nun
für mich es gibt noch eine wichtige
regelung die hier in deutschland gerade
getroffen wurde hochrisikoland
österreich das könnte vielen von uns den
winterurlaub verhageln richtig los das
wissen wir noch nicht wir aus
deutschland schlechter sicht haben
österreich zum hochrisikoland erklärt
das heißt erstmal für die regeln vor ort
nichts
was wir hören versucht österreich
unbedingt diese wintersaison
durchzudrücken auch mit 2g heißt dann
nur geimpfte genese kommen in die gondel
aber eben auch ins festzelt ins
partyzelt in die apres ski hütte das
könnte noch eventuell zum problem werden
wenn wir an die bilder aus dem letzten
jahr denken die mahnenden worte von
menschen wie markus söder die sagen wir
brauchen kein zweites ich dass uns quasi
die infizierten aus dem urlaub zurück
nach deutschland bringt also das wird
noch spannend zu beobachten sein aber
stand jetzt soll die wintersaison mit 2g
möglich sein diese garantie hat uns
österreichs bundeskanzler sebastian kurz
damals gegeben die ski garantie für uns
alle deutsche auch die apres ski
garantie wollte ernst zumindest fast
geben vor einigen monate kleines problem
kleiner haken an der sache ich muss mir
kurzer halt nicht mehr kannst